Speaker 1: So we looked at the Eric Trump
clips from the Reawaken America tour.
Let's now look at one Michael Flynn clip. Michael
Flynn is the former national security adviser
to the failed former president, Donald Trump.
Flynn was convicted and ultimately pardoned
by Donald Trump. He showed up and he said
Trump is currently the president. Trump,
not Trump, should be president, not
Trump one. But they didn't give it
to him. He is saying Trump currently
is the president of the United States
and people believe it and people cheer.
Speaker 5: And I still say and they and
wherever the damn live stream is, you know, Donald
Trump is still the president of the United States.
They can call me wherever they want. There it
is right there. There they can call me whatever
they want, because there's no way in the world
that 81 million I don't see 81 million people
wearing build back better hats.
Speaker 1: That's because there's no cult
around Biden. People just want a calm, normal
president and they want to live their lives.
Okay. So there's Michael Flynn. You know,
one of the things I genuinely wonder
if Trump is currently the president. Why aren't
they blaming Trump for the high gas prices?
If they believe the president is responsible for
inflation and they believe Trump is currently
the president, this is sort of like basic logic.
The President is responsible for inflation. Trump
is the president. Therefore, Trump is responsible
for inflation. It's along the same lines. The
question must be asked If Trump's currently
president, he obviously can't run in 2024
because that would be his third term. And we don't
allow third terms here. Oh, no, no, no. But that's
it's selective blame assignment, selective belief
in reality. And this I, I don't know how we fight
that. In any kind of substantive way. We just have
to outvote them. There's no other way. There's no,
hey, come over to our side. These beliefs are
so extreme and so far gone that I don't know
how. I mean, just think it's. It's middle
of May the elections in early November.
How how do we mass deprogram these people and
get them to see reason between now and then?
I just don't know of how we do it. And so far,
nobody we've interviewed has been able to tell me.
Let me know your thoughts if you think
there's any way we might be able to.